good afternoon I'm David thorburn
professor of literature and director of
the MIT Communications Forum I'd like to
welcome the audience and especially our
distinguished panel
uh my hope is that that uh uh we will
when the panelist when the panelists
conclude their presentations that we
will have a a lively discussion with
those of you who are in the audience and
the one of the great Hallmarks of the
Forum is the back and forth that occurs
in those question and answer uh sessions
so I hope you're preparing your comments
and your questions uh as you're
listening to our speakers it it remains
for me simply to introduce our moderator
to whom I'm especially grateful he's
made a long trip to get here uh and he's
becoming already in in the short time
he's officially been at
MIT uh Ethan Zuckerman has become almost
a kind of recognizable fixture on campus
he's already appeared in a number of
events he's so overloaded Ed with jobs
moderating and talking himself that I'm
especially grateful that he's been able
to make time for today's event one of
the reasons of course is that it's a
topic that's close to his own heart
something he himself is deeply
interested in it's hard to imagine a
topic more Central to our current lives
and to the digital future now impending
for all of us than the topic of
surveillence and citizenship and it's a
pleasure to introduce Ethan who will
introduce our panelists
well thanks so much David and thanks
everyone for joining us today uh I would
like to point out that uh by being in
this room and participating in this
event you two are under surveillance uh
since we video record and uh broadcast
all of these so something to keep in
mind as we get into the question and
answer section of this um as David
mentioned I I've just come over to MIT
and I I've spent the last eight years at
uh the burkman center for internet and
Society at Harvard where one of the
topics that I've been working on is uh
this question of Internet freedom and
essenti what are the different ways in
which the internet is becoming
constrained as a possible space for
discussion as a as a network public
sphere a lot of the research we've done
has focused on sort of very obvious
threats to that Network public sphere
things like government-based filtering
or denial of service attacks ways of
silencing different people uh but the
question of surveillance came up as the
notion of an implicit threat how does
the notion that you may be under
surveillance being watched in digital
spaces change how behave and and my
research partner at burkman uh H Roberts
thought about this for a while and came
back and said you know the problem with
this is that if surveillance is any good
you have no idea that it's there and
that tends to be true both in physical
spaces and in Virtual spaces the
surveillance that's actually there and
the surveillance that you imagine can
turn out to be radically different
things and in the space of the internet
when we study surveillance we often end
up studying the potential more than
anything else what could Poss possibly
be watched because on the occasions
where surveillance breaks and becomes
visible those are the moments that you
actually get a chance to watch it one
moment that's actually been fairly
fascinating as far as watching
surveillance inject itself into everyday
life has been different ways of thinking
about surveillance in the context of the
recent events of the Arab Spring and two
very sort of quick stories about this
one is that as I think everyone has
probably heard a dead horse beaten to
death several times uh the role of
Facebook within the Arab Spring what
many people don't know is that Facebook
in Tunisia where um the Arab Spring
really started was under intense
government surveillance and had actually
been thoroughly compromised by the
Tunisian government by the time people
were trying to go and use the tool the
Tunisian government had actually
installed at the national ISP a tool
that allowed them to grab the passwords
of everybody using Facebook and go in
and literally document people's social
networks coming out of it what was
fascinating was that this was actually
widely known in Tunisia changed how
people were using the tool but didn't
actually prevent people from using the
tool and in some cases in using the tool
in very very constructive ways the
Second Story on surveillance is thinking
about the ways in which citizens are now
in an age of participatory media having
the opportunity to surveil their
governments and to surveil each other uh
through the simplest of means the idea
that most of us now have mobile phones
that have powerful uh still in video
cameras that in many cases are able to
let us flip the equation a little bit
and engage in what some Scholars have
called suveillance watching from the
bottom up rather than from the top down
and in some ways if you think about the
triggering events uh of what went on uh
both in CID buid and Tunisia of
documenting protests and government's
violent reaction to it or in Egypt in
documenting police brutality that's the
victory of surveillance in some ways as
a counterveiling force to surveillance
so one way or another this view of
either being watched or participating in
watching is an idea that has profound
implications for how we think of
ourselves as Citizens in a digital age
and also thinking of ourselves as
Citizens in physical spaces we're very
lucky to have with us tonight uh three
Scholars who thought about this topic
from different angles at a tremendous
depth uh furthest from me we have Marcos
Novak who's a professor an artist as he
tells me a trans architect which is a
term that he promises to describe uh
that in term allows him to be the
director of the
translab uh at uh UCC Santa Barbara uh
we have in the middle uh Sandra brayman
a professor of communication who's
worked on the co-construction of
Technology law and Society uh she works
at uh the University of Wisconsin
Milwaukee
uh she's the author of uh change of
state information policy and power and
she's also edited a series at the MIT
press on uh technology and policy and
then closest to me we have uh Susan low
who is a visiting scholar of computer
science at at Harvard University uh
despite my attempts to rope her into the
burkman center she's not there yet but
she was most recently A A Radcliff
fellow uh prior to that uh had a
wonderful career distinguished engineer
at uh Sun Micro Systems and she has a
new book out uh called surveillance or
security the risks posed by new
wiretapping Technologies uh because
these people know vastly more about
surveillance that I could possibly say
I'm going to shut up turn the stage over
to each of them in turn for about 15
minutes to talk about what they're
working on and then we're going to bring
this into a dialogue uh with the folks
here but we're going to ask Marcos to to
lead off uh first by showing us a couple
of videos that help frame these issues
and then sort of talking about your work
in this space uh as as an artist and a
scholar so if you'll lead us on I'd
appreciate it thanks thank you it's
wonderful to be here uh and thank you
all for coming um I'm G to go quite
quickly because I have uh many things to
show in a in a Stato kind of way the
videos are actually embedded in the in
the thread that I'll uh that I'll try to
share with you uh so they're not
separate they're
just so let me just um I'm uh at the
University of s of California Santa
Barbara and I direct something called
the translab which is a lab whose
mission is uh the transformation that
leads to
speciation uh that uh has all sorts of
aspects there are too many words on the
on the on the screen for you to read but
what's interesting in this context is
that um it is a an environment that
tries to uh borrow from all the Sciences
the atomic uh the the fine grained and
uh use it use all these Atomic things uh
holistically to create new worlds and so
we borrow from science and biology and
from computer science and uh from
neurophysiology and wherever there is an
element we we try to learn from it uh
this leads to to ideas like trans
architecture and transvergence and uh
trans modality and many things that are
all about uh
transformation um this is uh this
environment is uh also affiliated with
with another uh uh apparatus that we
have a three-story High uh Sphere for
making virtual environments called the
alos sphere which I won't describe here
and uh both of these are part of the
Media Arts and Technology Program at UC
Santa Barbara which is affiliated with
the California nanosystems Institute and
what the what this slide shows very very
quickly is that it goes all the way from
art and music to computer science
eventually all the way down to
theoretical physics and the the the
director of of this uh won the Nobel
Prize for uh Quantum electrodynamics
David Gross uh so it's it's at a very
high level but also uh very wide in its
uh scope now um I'm not going to talk
about any of the lab work that we do and
I'm really not going to talk much uh
directly about my my work although the
attitude is implied I really want to to
take the opportunity to talk about
surveillance and citizenship and the
predicament that that we find ourselves
in now both in my own work and and at
Mat we're all interested in the future
and so I want to start with the future
and I want to start with sci-fi and to
make a reference to a novel uh called
accelerando which you can actually
download it has a kind of anti-copyright
um and uh it's written by someone named
Charles straw that you might know um and
it describes in it a society called the
AG galmic society which is a strange uh
word what is what is a galmic uh it's a
society run by these this sort of hacker
group that can get into anything in a
kind of surveillance kind of way uh but
instead of being organized around the
idea of taking it's organized around the
idea of giving uh so it's uh you know
this this person is acting as an agent
that is uh giving things away as much as
possible to to the dismay of everyone
who wants to keep things um the the idea
itself uh comes from someone named
Robert Levan and uh something that he
calls a galmic which is the you know the
marginalization of SC scarcity uh which
I I won't refer to except to just point
you there but what's interesting to me
because I grew up in Greece I speak
Greek I speak ancient Greek I read
ancient Greek and and and have this
other life to me uh is the word aalma
which means uh statue but actually a lot
more than statue so a galmic has to do
with this word agalma and we'll come
back to it at the very end of of my my
comments uh but uh we do a kind of
prehistory to to all of these things and
I've already stated that we're
interested in the future and so in a
sense in a research environment we want
to become future and as soon as you try
to do this you realize that well you've
got a lot of work to become contemporary
you can't assume that where you were
born when you were born was actually
contemporary with respect to your planet
uh you have to catch up you may have
been born in the rainforest and then you
have some work to do uh you may have
been born in the city and then you would
have work to do to become contemporary
to the rainforest uh so so you you
backtrack then you realize that well
everything whatever whatever you choose
to do well I have a history and in a
certain sense you have to become ancient
to understand the history of of what
you're doing and then as you all you
know know something of math you actually
can't just know the history of math you
eventually have to know how to derive
something you have to go to the princip
principles the principles are the the AR
the the the the Arc in architecture uh
and you have to become archaic uh you
actually have to get to First principles
and then once you've done all this work
backwards you might be able to get to
the future again but with a different
point of view so uh I want to show you
some bones and leave you with a question
that will unfold as I go forward so
suppose you saw these images as Costas
and I saw in in Italy this summer uh uh
so you you see these uh this bone
sticking out of the earth what would you
think I'll I'll just leave you with that
for for a moment now um I was discussing
this with my students and they they
directed me to a site uh for something
uh called take this lollipop has anyone
seen take this lollipop um so I'll show
you the video there's actually a website
that uh requires your Facebook uh
information
and once you give it your Facebook
information you see the lollipop with
the razor blade once you uh give it your
Facebook information it incorporates
your information in uh what you're going
to see now I'm not going to do this live
it would take too too long but you can
you can go to the site and do it you
would see something like this except
with your own information in the the
video
please
[Music]
my now this person is taking information
and and it it gets very ominous and in
reaction to that uh we have all this
other counter surveillance to protect
protect us from from characters who
would take our information and do bad
things to us and harm us so we have the
counter force and this is another thing
this is from today's news uh big brother
is watching there's there's a you know
some people are uh up at Arms uh for uh
discovering that with Federal funding uh
the these lights have been uh uh
commissioned or ordered or whatever
whatever one does with such things and
I'll show you a bit of of the the video
describing these the these lights um
they can you you each light is basically
a little computer it has a speaker it
has a camera it's Wii it's networked and
uh it can it can actually listen and uh
uh do um a lot of things which I'll
just I just let you watch for a few
seconds
minutes looks very very calming inell
Street's energy management system
creates the most flexible and longest
lasting LED luminares available flexibly
programmed and dimmed with additional
thermal monitoring our systems can
extend luminer life as much as 50% more
than current industry standards so the
argument begins with efficiency ing
music is
calming simply by taking advantage of
the nightly needs of your lighting
system you can provide full brightness
during Peak usage and then later say
when vehicular parking or pedestrian
traffic is lower reduce the lighting and
energy usage to not only save money but
extend system
life intell streets takes advantage of
the existing power supply and in many
cases can even reuse your existing
poles you can achieve a fully featured
system by simply changing the street
light the intelligence of the system
resides in the unique dual band radio
system and miniature computer so this
goes on like this it tells you how it
works it shows you that it's a network
it shows you how the information is
collected per lamp per Street uh all the
statistics that are gathered how it
responds to even the the light uh how it
has a speaker built in how it has a
computer built in um how it has banners
built in that can uh show Al all kinds
of information eventually if as I scroll
through you'll start seeing flags and
things on these banners too and
everything is information uh oriented uh
sounds good you know fine you don't need
to dig anything up we're all happy um
and I think uh intell streets also
enables a myriad of Homeland Security
features okay for more information call
your local agent contact us at info@
intell streets.com now now we feel safe
right now this is another thing that was
just released uh um the the ACLU uh
release this graphic regarding the
Patriot Act and regarding exactly how
much information is collected versus how
much information actually leads to
anything so how much you know how much U
protection we were promised versus how
much actually uh happen so
143,000 uh reports have been filed but
only uh 53 referrals have actually come
from it so there's a massive uh reaction
of collecting information with with uh
you know you can read the the numbers a
small return and then you you wonder
what what balance were actually after in
in doing these things of course nobody
wants bad things to happen and we should
be careful I don't want to sound like
like I'm demonizing good things but
there is this this funny word in here
Patriot and I want to I want to you know
I want to um use that as a as a portal
into something so there's the word
Patriot and uh if you happen to speak
Greek uh patri you realize uh you know
is a is a Greek word and that leads you
conveniently to Hector in the ilad
Homer's ilad and to a phrase which is
which is
interesting which means one Omen is
excellent of faultless to defend the
Fatherland so we have the Fatherland we
have the homeland security we we just
heard it right it's like it's right
there but this is spoken uh by Hector
who is being asked what Omens he's
watching about going to war and he says
you know I'm I'm trying to defend uh
Troy the only Omen that matters is you
know defend defending the the Fatherland
um now of course this is embedded in in
a in a long story in which there is also
Achilles who knows he's going to die but
dies anyway and there is odius and
there's a there's a there's a narrative
structure that goes from the ilad to the
Odyssey and what you see is is a
situation of Omens and protections in
The Iliad that yields eventually to
another narrative which is one about
attention and action and in The
Narrative of the Odyssey um uh Ulisses
or
odyusa learns how to Be watchful uh but
has to has to always tame himself right
from the beginning he's always watching
his own behavior versus the the the
signs that are around him
uh the next thing I want to inquire into
are some of the words of the of what
we're doing tonight citizenship and how
citizenship of course comes from City
but we forget we forget City actually
comes not from city as we know it it's
not Los Angeles or Boston it's city
state and we have this situation here of
surveillance and the state uh and so it
comes from a city state when a city
state was a police and a police had
citizens which were called Poes or
polies as a single one and from that you
have the word polite nice but we seem to
learn from it the word police which is
not part of that language it's like it's
it's a it's a it's a skewing of of ideas
uh another another word from that is
Ottis whose contemporary English version
is idiot and it means the private
citizen the citizen isolated from the
city okay surveillance and we heard
surveillance which I like very much we
think we understand but actually if you
look at surveillance it's not from
veiling it's from vigilance and
vigilance is from vigil and vigil comes
from Vigo and vigio comes from health
and health comes from eia and eia if you
look far enough back shows up in on this
star which is actually not a star it's
actually part of a circle so you have an
a notion of of uh the of the healthy
implied in surveillance which is
actually a circular idea which is then
taken to be used in other ways now let's
back let's go back to CSI and crime
scene investigation and forensics these
bones that were from Da Vinci that I
showed you if you see them like this I
don't know what you're wondering but
what if you saw them like this and then
you saw after the bone in the earth you
saw this now what would you
say this is H it's fake fake it's not
fake at all it's not fake at all it's
been for
centuries the no these are actually
under the Acropolis I have others from
ital but these are actually under the
Acropolis in Athens not far from this
there is something that once upon a time
looked like this very detailed uh you
know these things would be like you know
tiny um um it's the top of a building uh
that still exists in in in in bad shape
uh and you're about this tall here so
all that detail is in
there and this whole
rooftop is invisible to anyone you can't
see it it looks like this and it's
actually really really beautifully
designed uh but why would someone design
something beautifully if uh uh if you
can't see it so there's this word aalma
which actually doesn't mean statue it
means to do something perfectly
according to R which is a kind of
flawlessness uh because that's what you
do uh it's it's a it's a pleasing thing
for the gods but the gods don't really
exist because they're the laws of nature
in in this world view and it comes from
a world view in which the world is seen
concentrically and hence the concentric
view of Health now it it's embedded in
these ideas of of uh uh the timely the
good and the well formed which are
attributes of beauty Architects know
them as firmness commodity and delight
and it's always a hole it's always a
circle now what what do we do what we do
is we do this it's 100% the circle is
now all of a sudden 100% And as soon as
it's 100% it's actually something that
can be fragmented and the fragments look
like a circle but they're actually
fragments they're not a circle and
they're all broken up which which is
actually consistent with the state in
which things like this are found and
consistent also with with another state
can you can anyone tell me where this
is it's actually here
so this is one of the most amazing
buildings on the planet and yet it has
no place for humans and that is actually
consistent with this worldview in which
the balance and the health of things is
actually uh set aside uh this is the
work of Irvin verm he he's done this
with the philosophers this is the the
next image is the commentary of the
internet which knows so many things uh
about one worldview and another
and then a whole series of other
articles that I could show you but
what's interesting is is that this is
2008 about obesity and how it's how bad
it's going to be in 2030 and in two and
the map of it and then just a few days
ago uh you know how it's actually going
to be worse than we thought because even
though we knew it for a few years uh it
doesn't you know we're not learning
anything from knowing it we're simply
just proceeding as say along the same
line so here's a kind of situation we
have uh an epidemic of obesity and a
abundance of Edibles a Poverty of
nutrition an equivalent information
obesity also epidemic and abundance of
messages with a Poverty of meanings a
lot of signal a lot of noise and very
little signal and disintegration so I'm
I'm
finishing someplace in in the ethics
Aristotle says that ethics comes from
Habits and that that ethics the word
ethics actually means the habits of a
creature in its natural environment
behaving normally um we we forget get
all that and we forget that there was
once a culture there have been cultures
around the planet whose whose uh ethos
came from from a balanced education that
contained everything from Homer to how
you lived and how you how you fought
those ideas actually have contemporary
equivalents I'm showing a hyperbolic
space for the circle and I'm showing you
what a healthy planet looks like if if
you
actually if you actually let it happen I
was just there this summer it's in in
in Greece um uh but that's exactly
what's actually uh forgotten the the
wholeness of things and the health of
things uh is actually forgotten the the
the the finishing two words uh regarding
surveillance and citizenship is that
surveillance assumes an adversarial
relationship between people uh and
between uh oneself against oneself and
it assumes that the world is a dangerous
place from which we we must be protected
this view this alternative intervie and
the reason I'm ending on this slide is
that that isn't a necessary conclusion
that actually one could think of the
world as whole one could think of the
world as good one could think of the
issue that we have not as one of Defense
but as one of balance and I would I
would play some of these problems uh
there and uh thank you and that's
it it's incredibly stimulating I I have
to say as I sat down to prepare for this
I I had no idea that we were going to be
uh doing Greek Linguistics but I I I
want to ask you a followup actually very
specifically on that which is
um it's incredibly helpful I think to to
bring this into the realm of the polus
and to bring this into the realm of the
city state and to think about um what
you've put forward as far as sort of
polite and police and and one way to
read that evolution is sort of the
assumption that if we're finding ways to
treat each other as Citizens and
behaving the polite way that we would as
in a collective city state um then we're
were able to sort of stay in the balance
that you're talking about whereas when
we find ourselves going Beyond it this
is the moment at which we look for
someone to enforce and someone to try to
hold us within the balance I I'm
wondering if there are cases where the
sorts of surveillance that you're
bringing up in that video are less
Sinister and less worrisome than we sort
of all found those allseeing lamp posts
and I find myself thinking with your
last image on the beach I'm very
interested in uh The Dumping of
Industrial Waste uh off the coast of
Somalia uh a part of the globe that has
no functioning polus at this point and
therefore there's no way of policing
that space and the only way that we
could sort of think about keeping in
check people not dumping radioactive
waste uh where it ends up throw showing
up in the shores of that country is some
sort of ability to watch and wait are
there circumstances in which the polus
and the polite breaks down where we do
want the police and we do want the
surveillance to be into this aren't
there systems where we should be feeling
good about having a watchful eye that's
trying to keep us in the sort of balance
that you're hoping
for uh I you I saved an image U you know
regarding the the the Greek uh part is
this can this come back on please did it
go to sleep um um there there uh this is
this is the the the gravestone of
buckminister Fuller and uh there's it's
really interesting why says call me
trimtab but one of the things at
buckminister Fuller was that he stopped
talking for two years he was married he
had a new child he just didn't talk
because words betrayed him and he needed
to to to Think Through the words that he
used and so when he when he started
talking he wouldn't stop but he
reconsidered everything I I think we are
actually quite confused so regarding
your your question about surveillance I
think or the watchful eye I I think
there's a there's a huge problem there
and it's the indication of personal
responsibility I Need to Be watchful not
someone needs to watch for me you know
that that's that's a huge thing and then
regarding Somalia or uh you know my
example would have been what's going on
with Mexico and and Los Naros or elarco
in the new book that's out on that uh
that where you have a situation where
the state and its surveillance and its
uh its guardianship has failed um it's
curious if you're in this country and
you're watching the elections there are
plenty of people who think that any kind
of uh supervision is bad and that maybe
we should just abdicate everything and
then we then we have we have uh we have
chaos I the the the conclusion that the
pivot here is and I showed specific
books I didn't choose any books I chose
a set of three books Pia which means uh
the bringing up of children is something
that we are also failing at and
basically by the time you people get to
be adults in Somalia or in Mexico or in
the United States or just about
everywhere they don't really know
because we haven't really taught them
how to be
citizens so so then they need to be
watched because by then they're old
enough to carry guns and to break into
things and to do all sorts of damage but
they might have learned better earlier
and so I I don't think you can you know
I think I have you know regarding a
topic like this I have to place the the
U the topic in at this scale because the
problem is it as is at that scale can
can we just take note of dates when the
two Fullers died among other I just
before that slide goes away I think it's
fascinating the reference to the fact
that they die within uh within two days
of one another that's a that's a
wonderful observation I knew Buck thanks
oh you
did um so Susan I'm I'm hoping you're
going to um take us perhaps onto onto
mapira on some of this I know that that
you've been very involved uh with these
questions of how citizens uh get
involved with issues of cyber security
and policy and I I'm sort of hoping that
you're going to um bring this to us in
in a way that's uh closely tied into the
technology so I want to so I'm actually
going to talk about something else but
it will be Terra Firma okay um but I
might pull over there towards the end so
I want to start with three stories and
the first story is about East Germany in
1989 now at that point East Germany had
91,000 people working in the stazi the
East German secret police this was out
of a population of 16 million there were
173,000 informants in addition to the
91,000 people working for the stazi
which means one in 63 East Germans was
directly or indirectly working for the
German secret police so that means
people's wives people's husbands
people's apartment concierges or the
equivalent uh people's School teachers
people's nurses people's doctors
everybody was being spied upon by
everybody people didn't know who they
were being spied upon it was really
quite devastating once East Germany fell
but I've already told you the conclusion
which is that East Germany fell so what
happened in the spring of
1989 was that there was discontent in
the country over local elections but the
government itself was concerned with the
40th anniversary of of these German
Democrat well the German Democratic
Republic and it was focused all in the
celebrations
there in the summer and fall of um 1989
what happened is uh Hungary had opened
its borders to Czechoslovakia and a
whole bunch of East Germans fled from
East Germany they went into Hungary and
then across to Czechoslovakia the East
German government was very upset with
this they had been shooting people
fleeing East Germany for decades and
objected uh Hungary closed its borders
but the East German didn't stop fleeing
East Germany there was tumult there was
a
Revolution and the East German
government
fell now how could a government fall
when it was monitoring its people so
closely it's the first
story Second Story is about Iran and
Iran in 1979 so a decade earlier in that
case I want to talk about the US
government in Iran and the US government
at that point was very closely allied
with with the the Iranian government the
Sha was our friend uh and we worked
closely with the SHA uh now the Sha had
someone who opposed
Himi who was a dissident Mulla in Paris
shipping tapes that got played in masks
that didn't seem like much of a threat
except there were protests in the street
and protests in the street and protests
in the street and the Sha's government
fell and the US government had no idea
that this was going to happen and this
was a precursor to the kind of
complications that the US government
found post the end of the Cold War so
during the Cold War the US government
National Security the NSA the CIA knew
what they had to learn how many icbms
there were how powerful they were where
um where the German East German spies
were and so on they knew the issues they
had to confront they might not find the
answers but they knew the questions they
wanted to to find out when the Cold War
ended the game went from Sol finding out
secrets to solving Mysteries where the
biggest part of the mystery was they
didn't know what the mystery was in the
case of Iran they didn't know that there
was a mystery they didn't know they knew
that the people were dissatisfied with
government the the Iranian secret police
in that case the Sak was very active and
and the US certainly understood that the
Iranians were unhappy with their
government but they didn't know there
was a threat in terms of
ofi since the fall of the Soviet Union
and the collapse of of Communism we've
been dealing with many more SEC
Mysteries than secrets and the
complication with Mysteries is you don't
know where to look there are other
complications for US National Security
which are worth a minute which is of
course post 2001 it's become more
difficult for us National Security
Forces to operate in many parts of the
world and so they rely a lot more on
human rights workers and Industry
the oil people in in Nigeria the human
rights workers in in uh Indonesia they
don't employ them directly they just try
to monitor they try to find out what
they're learning but of course in order
to find out what they're learning those
people's Communications have to be
protected from the Nigerian government
and from the Indonesian government so an
interesting thing happening there the
third story I want to tell is a story
that hasn't ended yet it's Occupy Wall
Street um and that story is a story
where we have Facebook and we have
Twitter and we have a free press and
lots of
communication and until Occupy Wall
Street happened we didn't know that 233%
of the US population supported Occupy
Wall Street and was really angry about
the
99% now democracies only work with the
consent of the Govern here was a case
where the Govern were really unhappy and
the government didn't know that aspect
of it or at least a large piece of the
government if you look at the policies
being promulgated in Congress a large
piece of the government didn't
understand that so the surveillance and
by this I mean the surveillance by big
business Facebook and Twitter and all
the information that was available for
anybody who wanted to search didn't
capture the
unhappiness point is that privacy is
essential for democracy that's why we
have the First Amendment it's why we
have the Fourth
Amendment de Democratic discussions
happen first in private organizations
happen first in private and then they
move to the public sphere without the
Privacy you can't have democracy
acting I want to tell you two more
things one is that in our wonderful
Twitter
Facebook open-source world it's become a
lot harder for National Security to
operate for those of you that missed
Wikileaks secrets are a lot harder to
keep and they don't last as long and it
doesn't matter whether it's last year's
Wikileaks or whatever happens next year
um National Security is undergoing a a
change in which they understand they
haven't learned to operationalize it yet
but they understand that secrets are
hard to keep and they won't last long
and that means what you keep secret has
to
change I want to talk
last about the difference between
National Security and law
enforcement we tend to lump them
together after both after all both of
them want to discover what the people
are thinking and they try to do it
secretly but in 2000 we had a major
split between US National Security and
US law enforcement so before 2000 both
of them were arguing that
cryptography the tech the technology
that keeps communication secret
cryptography strong cryptography should
not be available to the masses now they
didn't argue this publicly they just
controlled it or the US government
controlled it through export controls so
computer equipment with strong
cryptography couldn't be exported could
be sold domestically but computer
manufacturers didn't want to sell one
type of equipment domestically and a
weaker type of equipment abroad because
it's really hard to sell the stuff
abroad when you say well it's really
fine oh yeah yeah we have something
stronger here also they didn't want to
support two different kinds of equipment
so for a long time between about 1975 to
2000 the National Security Agency the
NSA supported this type of ban first it
tried to ban ban the research in in
Academia and Industry then when that
wasn't successful it simply tried to ban
the the sale of goods and starting in
about the early 1990s the FBI was firmly
in the same camp before the early 1990s
the FBI hadn't been concerned about this
issue but in 1999 the two communities
split the FBI would still like to see
the use of strong cryptography withheld
within the United States but the NSA
doesn't in 2000 the NSA supported the
loosening of export controls in
2001 2 months after the uh attacks the
NSA supported the approval of a very
strong cryptographic algorithm for use
in in public systems this was an
algorithm that that was went through the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology but it was an algorithm that
was a billion billion times stronger
than the algorithm previously
available in 2003
the NSA supported that use the use of
that algorithm in classified for
classified documents now what that means
is that it it that algorithm will then
get used in a lot more equipment because
if it can be used for both classified
and non-classified purposes computer
manufacturers are going to just go full
force into into implementing it in 2005
the NSA supported the availability of a
whole Suite of algorithms not just to
encrypt communication
but in fact to secure networks
communication networks public algorithms
to secure communication networks so
what's going on doesn't the NSA have the
job of listening into everybody yes and
no the NSA has the job of listening into
everybody abroad and domestically the
NSA is actually concerned with
protecting domestic Communications and
me occasionally it gets asked by other
parts of the US government to listen in
on certain kinds of
communications but it's more concerned
with actually protecting domestic
Communications it doesn't say this very
loudly but I've just described a whole
trajectory of
behavior so the NSA wants to protect
domestically and listen in abroad so
when we think about surveillance we've
got a very complicated government
picture on it and um that's what's
informing things here and I'll stop here
and and let you ask some devastating
question well that's a wonderful set of
provocations there I mean I think the
the paranoids among us uh and maybe not
even the most paranoids amongst us um
might respond to the NSA Story by
wondering whether the NSA has has the
escro key behind all of this and and
that's really the solution to all of
that but you you've forgotten more about
computer science than I will ever know
you feel fairly confident that that
algorithm is secure so I uh yeah I I
feel fairly confident that the algorithm
is secure mostly because I would not
like to be NSA testifying to Congress oh
yes we knew that algorithm wasn't 128
bits secure but only 67 and we let the
banks and everybody else use it but we
KN because you don't want to be NSA
testifying like that you can say we knew
it was only 126 bits secure but to say
it was 90 bits secure you don't want to
be in that position let me tell you one
more story which was when I was writing
my latest book I was talking to the
technical director at the information
assurance directorate so NSA everybody
knows about the surveillance mission of
NSA that's 50 s uh 85% of the budget but
only 50% of the mission the other 50% of
the mission is information assurance
protecting Communications protecting
Communications of the US government and
what the technical director was saying
to me was that he was concerned about
land mobile radio so during a crisis
during a you know a Katrina a hurricane
Katrina a uh September 11th what have
you um cell phones don't work Wireline
phones often don't work um satellite
phones don't work if you're in the
canyons of New York or mountains or it's
cloudy what works is land mobile radio
and what the technical director told me
he wanted was to see secure
interoperable land mobile radio
available for sale in Radio Shack
because if it was available for sale in
Radio Shack every fire department every
Police Department every uh Hospital
would be able to interoperate during an
emergency well of course if it's
available in Radio Shack for the police
departments and the fire departments and
the the hospitals it's also ra available
for any criminal and he knew that and
then he said I shouldn't have said that
the problem with what he said was he
shouldn't have said Radio Shack they're
not allowed to talk about a particular
vendor but the statement was yeah he
wants to see it be beyond that I think
they've rebranded as the shack which has
a wonderful 1970s vibe to it that that I
I I'm realizing that that that we have
the blessing that that we get to talk
later tonight and I'm realizing the
first question that I want to ask you
then is the question that I'm going to
ask now because it's only fair which is
I I want you to just Place slightly
further with this notion of Secrets
versus Mysteries if if in the era before
the Cold War what we cared about was
Finding Secrets One of the implications
there is that we know who's important
and we know who's talking to whom and
what we simply have to find is the
message that Alice is telling to Bob
what you're talking about now with
mystery
is more a sense of something is going to
happen in some part of the world whether
it's Iran and the shaw falling whether
it's Tunisia and suddenly an uprising
successfully getting rid of a
dictator how does the National
Intelligence Community react to that
shift from secret to mystery um so one
of the things they did post September
11th was develop intellipedia
uh Wikipedia for the intelligence
agencies now they have a real conflict
there at the one level they want to
share information widely at the other
level when you want to share information
widely do you let every private get
access to the information so it's a very
complicated dance you have to figure out
what the pieces are that you're going to
protect and you protect very small parts
of it at the same time you want to look
very broadly and and that dance you have
to constantly re-evaluate and I think
that's that's the complicated part that
they're dealing with along with the
complicated part of now what piece of
things you actually really have to keep
secret what is the important aspect and
I I guess the way I think about it is an
analogy with
cryptography um it's really easy to
develop crypto systems where you know
you're protecting a Communications
Network and you have this set of keys
when you think of keros which was
developed here you have the set of keys
on a message you have this set of keys
on this service and so on and so forth
by the time you look at it you have a
complicated Key Management function and
it's only at MIT that I can talk in this
kind of way you have a complicated Key
Management function
but what I heard from Earl berbert
earlier this year is in any system you
develop you want to manage exactly one
set of
keys okay you want to keep only one set
of things secret and everything else
should devolve from
that okay same way with with keeping
nuggets really
small so what we're really talking about
here is the ways in which technological
change societal change political change
are co-evolving in one fashion or
another and here I'm I'm trying to move
into some of the language that that
Sandra's been using about all of this
and I'm hoping that perhaps you'll
you'll sew together some of these
threads that we've been playing with
into into perhaps something of a big
picture yes I think there are common
threads across what we're thinking I'm
going to come in with a slightly darker
um view but I think we are actually all
pointed towards the same sort of pieces
of light uh uh that are available to us
in this environment I start from the
position that there's uh no going back
on the use of the Technologies so step
one is for whatever your civil liberties
concerns just assume that they're here
assume they're always on so that would
be my uh response to marcos's uh
question about when is it on when is it
off just assume they're always on uh
there are ways in which uh the practices
of surveillance have changed uh the way
that the law operates uh we're
increasingly seeing The Disappearance of
the space between the ACT and the
Judgment if you're out there um if if
the minute you speed through the light
uh your license plate is captured the
judgment about you speeding is made in
the tickets in your mailbox by the time
you get home um steps in the legal
system that allow for other forms of
decision-making compassion judgment
evaluation have disappeared um we're
seeing uh some destruction to Fair
trials there are many ways in which this
happened uh post 911 but one of them is
that if you are brought to trial on the
basis of information gathered through
surveillance based on the USA Patriot
Act you don't have to be presented with
that evidence in the courtroom so you
can be convicted on the basis of
evidence uh that you are not familiar
with and have no opportunity to
counter
um there was a of course an effort after
911 to have an even higher percentage of
US population than the stacei did uh be
surveilling each other and the citizens
that the total information awareness
program which um what they said when
people when when there was an outcry
about that what they said was we're
going to stop talking about it they
didn't say they're not going to do it
they said we're going to stop uh talking
about it um and there's an impact on the
nature of citizenship so one of the
things that came in attorney general
interpretations after of uh statutes
after uh the after 911 was the idea that
if you had a relationship an
associational relationship with an
individual who was involved in one of
the activities that became uh defined as
terrorist that you would actually lose
some of your rights as a citizen and
there was a patriot act too that was
proposed um that would have had you uh
under which you would have ultimately
lost your citizenship rights um there
was a lot of outcry against the Patriot
Act too that didn't pass pieces of it
have been appended to legislation but I
bring this up because in the course of
surveillance of associations let's
remember that um in the US government's
pursuit of the wikileak event they've
now succeeded in getting uh information
about Twitter accounts and what they're
interested in is not only the IND the
particular Target individuals who were
uh twittering on tweeting on certain
subjects but everyone who was following
those tweets so that's an association
and so if uh in the course of the
surveillance of those kinds of
associations you lose some of your
citizenship rights um then uh we have an
impact on the operations of the legal
system and on the nature of citizenship
itself
changes that are coming because of
surveillance um and I point you all to
Susan's books if you want this sort of
single best way to to uh swallow that
information um but they're not the only
ones that are going on in the legal
system today we have uh many things that
have actually been quite um inversions
of our legal system Judgment of
intention rather than Behavior Uh
preemption rather than deterrence and
this actually links to the to the notion
of uh Mysteries Brian Sumi has been
brilliant on the difference between
prevention deterrence and um preemption
and of course if you're if you're
working with prevention and deterrence
you're working with uh know knowns or if
it's deterrence it's the Known Unknown
but you know what it is you're trying to
protect yourself against you simply move
into an ontological stance of constant
um preparing to defend against it when
you move into preemption you're in the
world of unknown unknowns and one of the
accomplishments of the way in which
terrorism and anti-terrorism has become
so fundamental to law around the world
there's Global harmonization driven by
the UN the USA Patriot Act was simply
the first Exemplar of that um one of the
things about uh terrorism is the fact
that it is not defined um there are
Global mandates for things that every
nation has to comply with in its laws
nor to fight terrorism but the
definition what you choose to stick in
that box gets to be locals so it could
be uh students in El Salvador protesting
um the bus uh arise in bus faires it
could in fact under contemporary US law
be every single person who's in an
occupied Wall Street or an occupied
Boston environment could be accused of
terrorism under existing statutory
law um we have um the question of the
border and and uh my difficulty with the
um optimistic distinction between the
international and the domestic is what
has happened to the border which is now
extremely permeable of course you have
not bright Geographic lines but broad
zones the US has exported the border to
uh other countries around the world it
has um established borders internally in
free trade zones the border is now
mobile uh if you're an immigrant to the
country you carry the border with you at
all times and all of these things are
particularly important because the
Department of Homeland Security has been
given explicit permission by Congress to
operate above the law when it is
protecting the Border also undefined
there is what is protecting so whether
or not you have any of these versions of
what's being defined as a border you
still might be protecting the border so
I think the um I would I would like to
take more Hope from uh the distinction
you've drawn than uh actually than I do
um and another thing that has changed in
the nature of our laws that it has
become practice driven rather than
principled driven we'd like to believe
that for a long time in US law at least
least is the case with which we're most
familiar here um that we started with
constitutional principles we worked down
through stages of operationalizing that
through statutes and through regulations
and then Judgment of individual cases in
the courtroom but at this point the
harmonization of anti-terrorism laws uh
that is now D Global has been driven by
what Interpol uh believes is most
necessary for policing practices it's
not principal driven it's practice
driven all of these things um have
generated a legal context even here in
the United States in which uh the
possibilities depending on National
leadership the possibilities for
repressive action on the basis of
information gathered for surveillance is
really quite extreme and it's not um
understood I Believe by uh most of the
population um we're also seeing changes
in the nature of the state and I here
I'll just point you to that book by
bremond about the evolution of the
informational state that that um is
worth mentioning here because of course
when we say the state there have been
many many changes since the Greek city
state or since the emergence of the
secular State several hundred years ago
and different forms of State specialize
in the use of different forms of Power
with our contemporary state which I call
informational specializing in the use of
informational power that operates by
manipulating the informational
foundations of Weaponry instrumental
forms uh organizations and rules Bureau
uhu Al forms of power and our
Communications our symbolic forms of
power and bring into being new forms of
power um so we're seeing um we we've uh
can fairly well document the evolution
of the informational State uh but there
are um I think we haven't given enough
thought to the con commitment emergence
of the informational citizen the nature
the concept of citizenship itself has
also changed over time although it has
always been been linked to con uh to the
notion of agency and to practice uh
latent citizenship in a sense passive
citizenship um has been um much less
important and not seriously treated
actually from a political perspective in
the way that active citizenship
practices have been emphasized Michael
schudson has pointed out that there have
been a number of uh different ways of
thinking about what's required to be the
informed good citizen over time did you
need to know what your party prefers
what your candidate prefers uh what your
rights are um the moment of uh having to
know how the world Works was just one
moment in that history and we've seen um
in the last couple beginning in the
1970s uh a lot of attention to changes
in the notion of citizenship in part uh
because of globalization practices in
part because of the impact of the use of
digital
Technologies the appearance of the EU by
the time we get um further down the line
and so forth and some of the new
Concepts that are coming up that have
been particularly important are the
notion of flexible
citizenship you choose your citizenship
for convenience at whatever the moment
Rupert Murdoch wants to be in Us Media
he simply becomes a US citizen we have
distinctions between Thin and Thick
citizenship how many features of your
social and political life are
Incorporated in the citizenship bundle
and how many are given up to other uh op
operations um we have contextual or
differentiated citizenship that what is
required of you and your citizenship
identity may be specific uh to
particular context uh Susan syby here at
MIT talks about the sociological citizen
the sensibility that um you're related
by uh your relational classes as opposed
to uh party lines or uh socioeconomic
class decisions that it operates more
sociologically which again I think is
what we're seeing with um the Occupy
Movement we we have the concerns about
robotic uh citizens uh we have in the
legal system attention to the
essentially the rights the legal rights
of machinic systems often treated as
more privileged than attention to the
needs of social citizens uh and so forth
from an informational perspective the
three dimensions of citizenship that are
particularly important um include uh the
developmental Dimension what are your
skills actually for operating as a
citizen historically the emphasis has
been on literacy and on production and I
think in our contemporary environment
again let's talk to MIT there's a lot of
emphasis on producing the content
producing the data um since World War II
we've begun to think about the
importance of access to information and
knowledge as what's required for
citizenship but I would argue that today
we need to be much more proactive and
include also the analytical skills we
have a lengthening referential chain a
lengthening causality chain and our
ability to actually manage that
information the glut uh that Marcos
referred to is something that is uh
relatively lacking still a second
dimension is fairness that you're
actually involved with the
decision-making on the basis of the
information you receive and that which
you uh distribute and there I would
argue that it still is important to
actually engage with the legal system to
actually engage with a political system
uh to be involved in elections and so
forth we've seen an interesting
phenomenon in Wisconsin when people who
chose not to vote went out to March and
complain about uh policies taken by
candidates after the election not uh
seeming to have lost the thread between
cause and effect uh when it came to
elections and policies put in place and
the third is the instrumental domain is
what you're doing actually effective and
I would put that challenge uh to the
feet of the Occupy Movement as well uh
Beyond uh making the very large point
that a lot of people are unhappy um
where it's going in terms of
Effectiveness is still not clear so I've
been thinking about what uh are some of
the techniques that the informational
citizen might be using Visa the
informational state in an environment in
which the most important forms of Power
are informational whether they're purely
informational or the application of
informational techniques to alter the
ways in which power and its instrumental
structural and symbolic forms um are
used we have some traditional techniques
we had the freedom of inform act you
have constitutional principles saying we
should know stuff about the state by the
70s you've got to put that into
statutory law at this point again post
911 significantly undercut um you no
longer if if an agency doesn't want to
release information and you drag that
agency into court all they have to say
is because we don't want to as opposed
to uh identifying the harm there's an
interesting um quidd pro quo if uh an
entity like a municipality decid decides
to share its information about things
like say infrastructure with the
Department of Homeland Security the
quidd pro quo is it never has to respond
to a Freedom of Information Act request
again and we have less information one
of the consequences of deregulation of
course is that less information is being
gathered about the corporations that
folks are concerned about about the
environment that we're concerned about
uh and other kinds of things regulation
is another uh way that citizens can get
knowledge of the state that is
traditional and I think this is actually
something that the Occupy Movement has
lost track of there's some confusion and
we could go into this more later I don't
want to tell the whole St we haven't
time to tell the whole story right now
but the uh concern about the effects of
the citizens united Supreme Court case
which released all of the restraints on
essentially released all the restraints
on uh corporate involvement in
elections um in a in a way that's
already significantly had an impact um
to to move from uh deregulating
corporate speech during elections to
saying we should have no corporations
operating as fictive persons is if you
extend that is to say that then there
should be no ability to regulate
corporations at all and we would know
less and obviously if there's no
regulation at all then the very things
that concern the occupi movement would
also be unfettered and the concerns that
they're um that they're speaking about
would become uh much deeper we have also
as a traditional means of knowledge of
the state simply knowing how the
government works and as somebody who
teaches the law I can tell you um uh
most of our students these days really
have no idea how it works even as
depicted formally let alone how it's
actually working for example the Office
of Management and budget in the white
house has put in significant constraints
on the use of the results of research as
inputs into policymaking that radically
changes the ways in which um our our
decision-making operates the notion of
the informed citizen or even the
informed politician changes its flavor
in that environment uh and so forth um
then we have the new ways in which the
informational citizen uh can operate and
some of these have already been
mentioned um the suveillance the the
surveillance From Below which I think we
could actually be more systematic about
and more insistent about um but one of
the earliest examples actually was
fascinating it was in the mid 1980s an
adult with arms control
ever since uh the end of World War II
folks have been talking about uh the
possibility of mutual verification so
you knew how many weapons were out there
and whether or not new weapons were
being tested and governments kept saying
we can't do it we don't have the
Technologies it's not the right thing to
do it's too politically fraught and
finally in the mid 80s the natural
resources defense Council an
environmental group and I can just
imagine this starts at 3:00 a.m. and
there's been a fair amount of drinking
um they're sitting around and they're
saying okay the governments won't do it
why don't we do it and they wake up the
next morning I'm this is my imagination
of the process but uh but Philip shre
has written a book documenting the
process um uh they they over a few days
they start realizing that maybe this is
a serious idea and so in 1986 US
citizens who are members of this
Environmental Group go and meet with
citizens who are members of the Soviet
uh scientific organization and they
reach an agreement to start surveillance
of um of what's going on in the nuclear
industry all over the Soviet Union on
the ground and they start acting on that
and they start verifying what's going on
in the development of nuclear weapons it
actually took much longer to get that in
play in the US than it did in the former
Soviet Union but that was what broke
open the entire verification of arms
control movement which then led to um
significantly contributed to Arms
Control reduction obviously research in
an area that I need to take up again
given recent developments but uh but
that was a fascinating example and a
great model I think of of citizens
surveilling where governments ought to
uh and aren't we see an example today
with Japanese citizens surveilling uh
radiation levels in Japan which the
government is seeming to prefer uh not
to do the leaking uh which Susan already
mentioned is extremely important from an
information policy perspective I think
it's a GameChanger uh but one of the
things we want to remember there and it
gets back to the issue of skills and
Analytics capacity is that the first
thing that Julian Assange did when he
launched Wikileaks was to put together a
massive datab base of information on
banking
activities that he believed would then
form the basis of of journalistic and
citizen investigative reporting and huge
barrages of analysis and critique at the
banking industry this is before the 2008
financial crisis he puts together this
massive database based on information
he's gotten through leaks he releases
the database and nobody touches it
citizens don't touch it journalists
don't touch it dead silence and that's
why when it when he got to the cables
and those kinds of information he went
and worked with the newspapers and did
it selectively and tried to shape the
editorial process because he found that
when the information was out there
people didn't actually use it uh we had
an example here of that earlier we have
what I'm calling Boomerang surveillance
and I kind of Lov this but some of you
may have caught the story um a week or
so ago that there were hundreds of uh
drug convictions that were abandoned I
think it was in both New York and LA
because it turned out the police had
been plant had to meet their quotas for
drug arrests and were planting cocaine
on individuals the convictions were
thrown out because in one case the
policeman uh described what he was doing
without realizing there was a camera on
him at the time and in the other case
the same thing happened the guy forgot
he was wearing a wire so um I you know I
don't know how we can promote more
consequences Boomerang surveillance yeah
and then we have on the flip side state
knowledge of citizens and I think of I'm
distinguishing between citizen knowledge
of the State and State knowledge of
citizens because at the Constitutional
moment there are actually 21 different
uh constitutional principles dealing
with uh information not just the first
amendment um but the initial notion was
some balance some mutuality so there are
princi mandating government exposure of
information about what it's doing to the
citizens and there are those things that
um give the state the right to know uh
to know things about citizens that it
would need in order to operate and that
actually goes back to just after the
French Revolution when we see the
appearance of the word surveillance in
the way in which we're using it now um
surveillance was one of the first uh New
Concepts to come into use in the in the
um after the French Revolution
ution at the same time that statistics
came into use as a concept in both cases
that the government needed to know uh
what it what its citizens were doing if
it was going to serve the citizens so uh
just very quickly um uh the overwhelming
of data uh we have the artist Hassan
elahi who has uh successfully found ways
of getting himself through airports by
revealing huge amounts of data about
himself uh to the Border guards
constantly um something that could be
done more um leaks again inter I'll put
this uh leaking on both sides because we
uh of course the US government has
massively used information uh that came
out through Wikileaks cablegate uh for
its own purposes one of the reasons it's
kind of ambivalent about what to do
about it right now um uh I've I've
written about and would just point to
the role of narrative creativity and
artistic creativity in this environment
if you are seeking modes of political
communication that will elude uh
algorithmic Det protection in online uh
environments The Narrative creativity
becomes particularly important and I
think there's um we keep talking about
the rhetorical turn within Academia but
the behavioral choices we talk about the
chilling of speech and maybe shyness
about seeking out certain information in
the online environment because we're
concerned about the always on
surveillance but I think there's a way
of manipulating that and again talk
about complexity but behavioral choices
and laying down your own a
trail um and then I just finally wanted
to talk to Everyday citizenship
practices and I think this links also
with both of the previous speakers if we
treat every public moment as a as a rest
public uh Hannah AR's uh description of
that as the shared table between us as
we build the world in which we live in
together then treating any moment if if
we think of privacy as a boundary
defining mechanism than any moment in
which we are mutually sharing
information with each other can itself
be defined as a polace as a moment in in
which uh politeness and civility are
needed and I think if we thought about
those things um in EV in every one of
our interactions it would also uh do us
some good in reversing some of the
extraordinary changes we've seen in what
we consider acceptable political
Behavior acceptable political discourse
uh and acceptable political
leadership so SRA in some ways you you
had promised a darker Vision than we got
from Susan and you put perhaps the most
optimistic idea that I've heard so far
tonight which is this notion that we can
think of Regulation as a form of
surveillance and that if there's one
thing we might ask our friends over at
occupy to be pushing for regulation is
it and what I'm wondering is
whether it's reasonable to take your
wonderful provocative example of
environmental groups monitoring nuclear
disarmament and try to apply it to
something of the complexity of say the
financial system where it seems like one
of the major problems we've had is an
utter and total failure to regulate in a
meaningful way or at least in an
anticipatory fashion but you offer the
sort of intriguing possibility that we
might in fact find a way as Citizens to
surveil and understand that system
whether it's through a sanja's database
or whether it's through some other way
of going are we letting governments off
the hook if we take on that sort of
surveillance capacity on our own or are
we in fact engaging as these sort of
informational citizens that that that
you're projecting that we're becoming
well there are about 18 different
questions bundled up in that um uh I
the part of what happened with the
banking system was that the government
was failing to operate on existing
regulations so for example about the
mortgage crisis or about
um you know Ponzi schemes there was
plenty of warning that was not acted
upon so uh some of it is is still
monitoring government and holding the
government accountable which it has now
begun to do
uh the I do think that um I would come
back to I think the skill level what I'm
really concerned about um in terms of
whether or not the Occupy Movement is
thinking about
regulation um is the low level of
analysis so which is why I brought up
the citizens united case I it is in an
environment in which um what's one of
the things that's going on in the
financial system is this um stochastic
uh multiplication of levels of
probability that you get with
derivatives so you're betting on things
that you have no idea where they are um
to move from that into just like abandon
the regulation alog together is to take
is to take um what used to be trained as
the ability to at least follow a
multi-step argument if if we can
fantasize that there was a moment in
which our literate uh educated
population could follow a multi-step
argument um we're in an environment in
which the length of the arguments that
need to be followed has gotten longer
and it seems as if the political
conversation has gone to singl step
arguments um so I one in your in your
question there was both um should there
be more regulation
it depends on what it is uh I I'm not
just saying we ought to regulate but we
ought to recognize that regulation is a
tool for acquiring information when the
Office of Management and budget says
don't get information about the children
to migrant Farm laborers because it's
not cost effective for the agency to
collect that information then we know
we're not providing those children with
education or with Health Care um
secondly is the question of whether or
not the government is actually operating
in accordance with the regulations that
in place and that I guess then third is
uh our the our importance um as Citizens
if we want to to make use of that
information and enhancing our own
analytical skills and intellectual
sophistication regarding what's going on
so I I want to I want to grab that
notion of analytic skills and sort of
put a question to all of you that I'm
I'm hoping will sort of synthesize some
of the threads that that came through
here
um one of the ideas uh that Mark was put
on the table early on is is this notion
of overload and this notion of
informational overload and one of the
technological changes that's sort of
gone on in an era of social media in an
era where our lamp posts are spying on
us uh is this notion that we have vastly
more information than we even had in the
days where one out of six of our fellow
citizens were were spying on us at the
same time Sandra you're you're positing
this idea that we need this sort of
third level analytic skills Beyond just
being able to produce information and
access it but being able to analyze it
and so what I'm wondering in all of this
is there's a seduction of surveillance
there's this notion that somehow if I
can watch and if I can have an eye on
the world as someone in a position of
power I can know and I can anticipate
and I can find the secrets and I can
Unriddle the Mysteries but there's also
this interesting potential sort of
coming at the moment that by having all
this information coming in if I don't
yet have the analytic skill if I don't
have the way of synthesizing all of this
then maybe I know in fact less that than
I might know
before what's that tension between is it
possible that all of us who are worried
about surveillance are actually and
someone's worried about the wrong thing
is maybe
somehow the absorption of all this data
and the fact that we're being watched in
so many different ways does that
actually make it easier for us to hide
in ways that that we might have uh in an
earlier age I don't know if you want to
jump I want to jump in first um I've
been thinking about wire tapping for a
long time first because I was very
interested in cryptography and then
because I got very interested in
wiretapping and when I was working at
Sun it was very hard to work on
wiretapping from a civil liberties
perspective both because there are
plenty of people at ACLU who can do it a
lot better than I can and because it's
not a sun issue it's not a sun
shareholders stock shareholders issue
but um it was of concern to Sun because
wiretapping and building wiretapping
capability into
uh Communications networks does affect
Innovation and the pace of innovation so
sun was very concerned about laws that
would require that uh so I had Sun
interested but this was the mid 2000s
and to go down to Washington and say you
can't build surveillance in because it's
it's bad for Innovation it's not a an
argument that would work post September
2001 however you could talk about the
threats to security when you build
surveillance into security into
Communications Network works you create
security risks and in fact you create
lots of security risks security risks
that parts of the government are
actually quite concerned about and so I
began following This Thread pushed to it
somewhat by necessity but also pushed to
it because it was in fact of great in
great importance and um what you f what
I have found as I began writing this
second book was at one point I stopped
and I said now why is this person from
the NSA talking to me and that person
from the NSA talk and that I began
looking at all the different are they
using me and I thought well wait a
minute if they're using me they're using
me in a way on an argument that I
actually believe is correct and I'm
using them and they're using me and
that's okay um and so I would say that
yeah within the government there are
people who say sure it would be nice to
have that data I can always use that
data but you know acquiring that data
also puts us at risk building that stuff
in puts us at risk and that data isn't
so valuable to me that it's worth
putting us at risk so I would say that
within the government you certainly see
people who who view it that way I view
it that way there are lots of people
outside the government who view it that
way that acquiring the data is not
always so useful and having the
analytical skills that Sandra's talking
about is actually critical can't think
analytically the data isn't going to do
you any good at all so so Marcus one of
the provocations you put forward is sort
of the notion that this data could be
collected almost anywhere that that
whether it's on the street whether it's
on Facebook how how does that leave you
feel about this question of of whether
we get overwhelmed at a certain point
Even in our own active surveillance does
it at some point the surveillance become
self-defeating or uh do do our
capabilities sort of scale to measure
with that I'm listening to the
conversation and I'm I'm really uh
fascinated by how the conversation
itself illustrates what I was pointing
to which I think hasn't really
registered and may not register for a
long time that that uh there are two
models that work one which is a a pie
chart and one which is a concentric
system and that it's we're totally
seduced into believing that terraferma
is our piece of pie and I have to say
very simply that curing the leaves
doesn't fix the disease in the roots and
we have a root
problem and uh we can talk about the
details we can talk about the technique
we can talk about all sorts of policies
and little things and never get to the
root so uh I can't you know I mean it's
it's really really interesting but um as
I'm listening I'm thinking of uh
something that I would call the
arrogance of the
presence present of the present which is
um that we think because we're now that
now is what's
important and we don't we don't dare
think what Florence must have thought
before the Renaissance which is that uh
uhoh where Thousand Years late some
other people had this right and we've
been screwing up for a long time and we
had better become daring and fix it I'm
saying that because I think in in what
we heard we heard you know the uh you
know the really interesting statement
that uh people didn't know about the the
Occupy Wall Street that didn't know that
people were unhappy which is really an
incredible
savementa that n Chomsky has been saying
this
he's been saying it for 40 years he's
been referring to James
Madison who's been referring to
Aristotle to whom I referred to not by
accident and I can pull up the quote in
which James Madison in the writing of
the Constitution states that the role of
the Constitution and I'm now quoting
both Madison and
chsky the role of the Constitution is
the protection of the opulent few from
the
many it's been known for 2000 2 and a
half thousand years that this situation
will happen happen it has
happened for with all sorts of
consequences all over the planet it will
continue to happen because we don't want
to look at the
problem we you discuss dimensions of
citizenship it was fascinating to me
that in the dimensions of citizenship
citizenship one of the dimensions of
citizenship isn't the consideration of
the good like how do we make a society
that is actually good for people not how
do we spy on people more efficiently how
do we make the place better to begin
with it's not a new idea but you have to
be totally arrogant to assume that all
the new ideas belong to the now and if
you realize that maybe some other people
got some things right it might be a good
idea to listen to good
advice um I don't know that I'm
answering your question directly but I
want to point out you think you might
think I'm not answering directly but I
but I want to point out something
tangible and economically true you know
it was on the radio the other day it's
unfortunate that Steve Jobs died you
know everybody you know seems to to have
liked him for all the
complaining it was it was reported that
uh when they were making the apple one
he was fussing with the engineers about
the circuits not being neat
enough and the engineer saying well what
do you care no one will see them the
computer works just as well what what
are you weing he says no I'll know it
and you'll know it
that is actually the word I don't know
where he picked it up but the idea that
you do something well because you do it
well because you're watching over it and
it's not anyone's surveillance that's
making you behave
well that is a that's the idea that
actually produces civilizations so I
want to say in this
conversation I think it's important and
I'm I'm embedded in technology I'm a you
know Pioneer I've done the first thing
in in in I've been the first to do
something on the the planet for several
things that I've done in my field so I'm
not afraid of any of this but I have to
say
technology equals slash does not equal
civilization you know and here's here we
are at MIT it's it's not just about
about the skills it's not the analytical
skills won't get us there I don't think
they'll get us there because we're not
looking at the roots so you know let me
let me add one more thing because the
word mystery came up and and this thing
about words is actually not me just
exercising Greek it's about
confusion the word mystery does not mean
mystery the root Mis actually means
muscle what it actually means is those
things that you have to exert yourself
to learn you have to exercise it's
difficult for most people to do that so
they don't but a mystery is simply
something that you have to exert
yourself you want to learn mathematics
you're going to work at it you want to
play the piano you're going to work on
it you want to have a good Society
you're going to work on it
why don't I open it up at this point and
uh let's see if uh anyone else wants to
jump into this conversation uh which is
complicated and multi-layered I invite
you to jump in on uh questions of
surveillance on citizenship uh whether
they're contemporary or whether they cut
back to the roots uh I'm going to ask
that uh questions be interrogative
statements that preferably uh end with a
question mark at the end of them and
let's start there Hi um so I have a
question for Susan and a question for
Sandra the question for Susan is based
on um your point that uh privacy is
requirement of democracy and that uh you
know democratic practices begin in
private deliberation and then get taken
in the public sphere so in my
introduction to Civic media course we
were talking about this idea and one of
the Notions being that subaltern
counterpublic and social movement
formations before they become visible
have always done this but now as
increasingly this activity moves online
um are we losing some of the private
space that uh social movements in early
stages of formation um used to enjoy
before they move into the public and
should I do the question
for well so let let's just pause for a
moment here by the way this is Sasha
Katan chak uh of uh comparative media
studies here we're also going to ask
questioners to identify themselves uh
only because I love Sasha very very much
does he get two questions everybody else
gets one but we're going to stop you
here uh and let Susan actually answer
the question and then uh we're going to
let you ask question two and it's you
and only you so in fact you know if I
hadn't known if if if Ethan hadn't told
me who you were I would have said Gee
this sounds like more a question that
one of the burkman people should ask
perhap answer perhaps Sasha constanza
Clark for example um it's you're really
asking a social question and I feel a
little bit out of my expertise there but
I'll answer it anyway because I'm
sitting here and I have to um and the
answer is um I think Occupy Wall Street
gives a really good example of that so
there was some organizing by adbusters
and so on prior to the occupations
starting to happen but lots of people
turned up who weren't part of that
conversation um and I think that you we
have always had some people who are
willing to be public early and some
people who aren't willing to be public
early um and I think that um
the media
enables the New Media enables those
public dis those discussions to happen
and they may appear to some people that
they're more private than they actually
are but the people who really need to be
private are going to stay private and
they're still going to participate but
they're going to stay private first and
and the question uh for Sandra is really
about secure communities so there's a
big you know discussion and debate um
both within and around the Immigrant
Rights Movement um around secure
communities and sort of the history of
it so escom um is the information
sharing program between local police
agencies and um and Ice um and the
debate is around at what point you know
do what what do you what do you know
from looking at sort of the flow uh of
that
program as it's originated and then
spreads you
know the debate is to States and local
police agencies who are now saying we
want to be able to opt out of this so
that we can do more effective policing
in immigrant communities is that really
true or is this part of sort of a public
play that's being put on so this is a
debate that's raging around whether
there's just a pretense here and that
there's a sort of good cop bad cop thing
going on as secure communities extends
uh around to every local agency so some
states have tried to opt out and they
haven't been able to and that that was
that's where the controversy has come so
I'm really curious if you you have more
information about that um from looking
at the spread of different I guess
surveillance programs through different
arms and state
agencies do you want to quickly Define I
for everyone uh immigrations and Customs
Enforcement so this is not something
I've looked at in depth myself but we uh
want to be aware of being monolithic
about treating everyone who's involved
in criminal justice or in the military
um is if they're all going to take the
same perspective and we want to remember
that over 3 50 m in in over 350
municipalities the uh the police force
has taken the position that it will not
follow certain um mandates that would
flow from the USA patriot act so um I
don't think it's good cop bad cop I
think uh in the cases where we're seeing
that kind of thing it may
be good faith best practice beliefs on
the part of those who are taking those
positions so let's get another question
please identify yourself and then fire
one ready
hi I'm John Hawkinson I write for the
MIT student newspaper sometimes about
cameras on campus and I wonder about the
role of the citizen uh it seems like MIT
Security Office adds one prominent
camera every three or four months
somewhere on campus uh and they say the
footage from those cameras can only be
used by approval of the MIT campus chief
of police um but I kind of continue to
be a little concerned uh recently
they've started adding remote controlled
cameras that can move and change what
they're pointing at us and there's one a
top mit's 20 story building up there um
and I'm not sure what to do about these
things we print notes about them in the
newspaper there's very little feedback
that we receive it seems very few people
care or are concerned so I wonder about
the role of the citizen I sort of
Despair about it but I I ask you what do
you think the citizen should be doing in
reaction to surveillance in their local
communities like
that Marcos do you want to take a crack
at
that well I I think
um I think you should assume that
everything is visible you know I think
that you know I think we all agree on
that that that any notion that uh that
something won't leave a
trace uh is unlikely to change for any
any time and I you know I don't know
that uh there's much to do about
that
um so I would actually like to jump in
which is that one of the very good
arguments as we have more and more
surveillance is to constantly ask the
question well how effective is this how
much are you spending on it how much
time is being spent watching those
cameras what could you be doing
instead and the effectiveness argument
is actually remarkably effective um so
there I will point you to an article
that appeared in Communications of the
ACM um I want to say about a year ago by
Angela Sassi on looking at CCTV closed
circuit television in the UK which has a
a remarkable number of cctvs and how
that wasn't they they aren't they do not
appear to be particularly effective and
I would try to use the tack of
Effectiveness there's only a finite
amount of budget is that where you
should be spending it on instead of
accompanying people walking back to
places at night or whatever it is and um
it's it's sort of the counterpart to the
security argument versus civil liberties
argument uh that I've been using on
wiretapping uh and if I can jump in here
with I think it's it'll be a ther um so
in response uh to your immediate
question those were the th that's where
I was offering the kinds of techniques
like Nar narrative creativity uh
designing behavioral streams in response
to the expectation it'll be uh
surveilled uh we actually there are
theater groups who are doing this now
with those kinds of cameras and so forth
so I think there are those kinds of
techniques available I would attach them
to a a response a response to Sasha and
the question about um where the Privacy
goes and Point again then to the to the
need for narrative creativity as a means
of speech even when you're in public
that would still be private and you know
there's thousands of years of practices
of that kind and and it's time for sort
of some reinvention uh in that domain
and I would attach both of those to your
question about um when is too much
information too much information because
there were really two separate things
there one is can you ever achieve total
meaningful knowledge well no and the
history of Arms Control is very
instructive in that regard because it
was clear that you get this ever greater
multiplication what started as a simple
rule turns into hundreds of pages of
protocols about how to do it and there
never is enough information because it
all boils down to political will in
order to achieve political will you need
argument and in order to achieve
argument you need the analysis so I'm
going to bring all those three together
thanks very much let's take another
question uh from that side please
identify yourself Jon hi um thanks for
the interesting discussion I'm Sunny
sidu I'm one of the master students in
the comparative media studies program
right now um my question concerns a sort
of repeated Motif that uh keeps
recurring in some of the criticism about
the Occupy protest movement I think I've
seen it enough times that it qualifies
as a meme and that's the sort of snarky
observation that uh a lot of people here
seem to have Apple computers and I I
think what's what's unspoken there is
sort of you know isn't this a little bit
hypocritical you know they how can they
say that they want to keep corporations
at an arms length if they embrace the
products from the country's largest
corporation you
um so I kind of I think that there there
might be a spark of something
interesting there which is that Hardware
like software designs can kind of be an
overdetermining structure to which we
all must submit if we want to use them
um and I was wondering if you could all
talk a little bit about sort of the uh
end user identity politics of of
Hardware choices and and whether this is
something that people can escape from
and and whether something needs to be
done in order to sort of uh defend
against these sort of politically
motivated statements please um I think
it's a really interesting uh question
you know the the
thing it's not a it's it's not a matter
of the 99% demonizing the 100% or or all
corporations or all that it's really a
question of motives and incentives and
priorities and apple winds up being uh
in the position that it is because it
seems that that Steve Jobs actually was
behaving with a code of Integrity that
everyone else is not not going by to the
point where again it's been reported in
the recent news that his last uh advice
to Tim Cook who was going to take over
was not for him to try to do what Steve
Jobs would have done but to just do
what's right and it sounds you I know
that everything I say sounds like a
generality but that's only because we
have this massive filter on our head
that says that if it isn't a piece of
the of the of the pie a little piece of
the pie chart it's not sharp and we
actually have to to realize as I think
Steve Jobs and Apple
proved that you can operate completely
differently and completely effectively
and completely to the benefit of
yourself and your corporation and also
the whole of such things that are made
with these Technologies these things
wind up being better made than they need
to be made they're made better because
someone cares to make them well everyone
else is actually having a different
priority which is not coming from a
positive place it is to to earn more in
a certain sense or to protect from a
danger or or you know in any case to
assert either a negative or or a kind of
uh selfishness of a kind I I think
that's what made Apple different that's
why those people love
it and I'm not a spokesman for apple and
I have no no such thing but but I you
know I think it's uh it's it's really
something singular and it's to be
explained it's not
inexplicable and I don't think it's a
mistake that he was a Buddhist you know
and I'm not a Buddhist but but I think I
think that's not not actually a
mistake the uh style thing can work in
both directions I'm reminded of Phil
agre who uh in the early 90s was saying
look if you want to keep your email
private write your own program
idiosyncratic program so when you take
it down um off the net nobody can track
it and I thought that's great Phil I'm
glad you can do that I can't do that um
it does draw our attention to different
what are the kinds of literacy we need
in this environment but I think that
that becomes actually more pretentious
than as I have deep admiration for Phill
but that that was more pretentious than
simply picking up the tool that's there
and I I think there's also there's like
a cost benefit analysis that the
individual makes do I want to spend my
time trying to mod my own computer or
make one from scratch or do I want to
like get down to the job that I'm here
to do and take the tool that works
that's available that I can
afford so I would go with Sandra and say
that I have an apple because when it
breaks I can fix it and that's not true
with the other machine machines for me
and I'm telling you about my level of
skill I know when my Apple breaks except
for the time that the hinge broke but
every other time my Apple has broken I
knew I could fix it and that enabled me
to fix it um at the same time I was
visiting a Google engineer last week and
he was really mad because he can't play
with the code the same way you can play
with on a Linux so I think those are the
two images that I have about the answer
to to why apple or why not Apple I'm
giving you a technologists answer and
that doesn't answer it for the rest of
the people over in Occupy Wall Street I
I am somewhat amused by the fact that
when you come and do these events one of
the things that that David tells you as
the moderator is that he he doesn't want
us to put bottles of water on the table
because it looks like we're advertising
the brown of water I I'm hiding my diet
coke down here so that you don't see me
endorsing Diet Coke but I I realize
implicitly that we sort of look like uh
we we're making a proapple argument here
I I have to argue that that's purely
incidental it isn't in fact intentional
let let's take a question over
here hi um my name is Kate I work for
the ACLU of
Massachusetts um I was really interested
to hear the differing responses to the
question about surveillance cameras um
Marcos it sounded like you said
basically there's nothing you can do um
don't walk around naked in the street uh
Susan your response right I mean you
said everything you do is visible um
assume that I did I did but I also I
also you know I I think there are things
that we we we've forgotten and we won't
even consider the culture that I was
pointing
to had people walking around naked in
the streets and it was okay our shame is
a really bizarre thing it's not really a
natural thing that a bad example I mean
essentially you said you know assume
that everything you do is public right
Susan your response was um you know that
you should make an argument about
efficiency and efficacy um I find that
to be a really Troublesome response
actually um and I think it's interesting
in the context of what you said earlier
about privacy um being a necessary um
Quality in in a democracy those two
statements don't really mesh so well I
guess you could say tactically that the
the former would work better in some
circumstances but I actually think it's
really important for privacy Advocates
to to Advocate the latter position um as
a a principle um you know on ideological
grounds but my question I think is is
going to be interesting in in light of
those two responses uh to hear what you
we what you folks have to say um it's
sort of the final frontier of privacy
and the final frontier of surveillance
which is mind reading um and you know
people don't discuss it very often it's
certainly not discussed in the Press
hardly ever um but really uh rapid
advances in mind reading technology are
being made by um doctors actually who
are looking into the science in order to
communicate with people who have ALS um
and such things but I'm sure many of
many of the people in this room would
not be surprised to hear that it's the
military that's funding This research um
and you know me as a privacy Advocate
the thought that the government will in
10 years be able to pretty accurately
read my mind is terrifying um and so you
know my question to all of you
is essentially you know is that is that
is there a bridge too far you know are
there are there some technologies that
we just like should not even you know
flirt with should we you know try to get
organizations like the ACLU to outright
ban mind reading technology in the
United States um to ban mind reading in
the state of Massachusetts so that
there's a free place um where you can go
you know in 20 years where you know the
FBI won't be able to read your mind at a
traffic light or wherever um and so I'm
curious to hear what you have to say
sort of in the context of your answers
to his question about
cameras so um um I want to say on the
Privacy versus efficiency I rely on you
guys to do the Privacy argument and and
that's actually an important point I
think that if you can argue
Effectiveness and efficiency you don't
have to get to the Privacy argument and
here I'm talking politically and not
philosophically philosophically what
drives me there is the Privacy argument
politically it is much more effective at
times to make the efficiency argument if
every time you pull out the privacy card
the privacy card stops working so well
so sometimes you don't want to pull out
the privacy card and if the thing isn't
effective and I'll pull back to the
National research Council computer
science and Telecommunications board did
a report on Data Mining and behavioral
surveillance and they said first
question you want to ask is whether this
stuff is effective each particular thing
you want to do because if it's not
effective you don't have to debate any
of the other issues and I think that's
really important I think it's um I think
it's a very valuable lesson second
before I get to mind reading uh I want
to talk a little bit about location data
so of course all of you uh except for me
because I keep my cell phone mostly off
uh all of you are beaming your location
all the time but there is a case coming
up to the Supreme uh to the courts now
about location data and whether or not
the police should have to have a warrant
to put a GPS tag on your on your car and
track you now the police can put a
beeper on your car and they can follow
you through tracking the Beeper but when
they follow you through tracking the
Beeper they have to keep you under
reasonably close visual surveillance and
they if they're not doing that they
don't know within a couple of blocks
where you are uh sometimes more than a
couple of blocks sometimes a half a mile
if they have a GPS tracker on you they
don't have to track you physically which
means it's a lot cheaper to do it means
they're sitting sitting in the office
and they're doing it um it means they're
getting much more precise data and the
argument by the technologists is this is
effectively a very different kind of
tracking it's technologically different
and therefore it can't go under the same
rules as the Beeper argument it changes
the the the
technology okay and there's a case that
came up to the Supreme Court kylo in
which thermal imager was used us to
detect whether or not somebody was
heating their house high enough to uh to
grow
marijuana and the police argument was
that they didn't go inside the perimeter
of the house and therefore they didn't
need a a warrant and the Court ruled
no what you can see from the outside of
the house not by standing by the way
next in front of the bushes and looking
in through the window but by standing on
the sidewalk you don't need a warrant
for what you need to do by going inside
the house you need a warrant for and the
thermal imager essentially goes inside
the house it changes the police
capabilities the argument in the
location data by the technologist is it
changes the capabilities so now I'll
finally get to your question about the
mind reading that changes our the police
capabilities and I would like to argue
it purely on that way uh I'd like to
argue it also that it is so intrusive
that it that one should never use it but
certainly it changes capabilities a huge
amount
I'll take you one further um so we're
about 10 12 years past the point when
the Department of Defense first issued a
call for research on the co-design of
humans and
weapons so you've got a certain kind of
uh intelligent weapon but you want to
design the eye to go with it and so
forth um the reason that I started uh my
introductory comments by saying um
there's no stopping it is because
because we're that's the kind of animal
we are we you know there were people who
before the first atomic bomb was tested
actually there were scientists who
believed it could possibly ignite the
atmosphere but you could not use it
we're not going to be able to stop the
use of surveillance Technologies and
development of those Technologies it
simply isn't going to happen it's not in
our species to do that uh so I think
there but there are levels there are
layers and stages of acceptability of
the use the first time in US law that
the ability to take into account state
of mind uh showed up was in Lial law in
the in 1974 when it was deemed to be uh
Poss that that was an argument in court
state of mind that you could use that um
and so I'll I I will again point to the
law as a place where we can look to
guidelines about when and when it's not
going to be um acceptable I'm with Susan
on um the fragility and and perhaps
thread bearness of the Privacy argument
and I say that as some somebody who
lived off the grid for 10 years and
loved it you know no phone no uh visuals
no nothing um it was wonderful and I
deeply appreciate the role of privacy
and what it is to be human in the most
profound ways but I also at this point
believe we are actually at a moment of
species change and that uh to to learn
that's that's true for many reasons um
I'm not into the whole transhumans send
us off the planet uh Zone but I do think
that it's a moment species change and
what it means to have the the intimacy
of the conversations whether personal or
those we need for public purposes in
terms of forming organizations all of
that is we're into new territory there
in terms of of um how to think about
it Marcus we'd love to hear from you on
this um well to to to keep uh to keep
the salad nice and and tossed um uh I uh
I wouldn't be literal about the the
trans humanist or or anything like that
but I would say that among our
arroganz I think we will continue to
evolve and it'll take some time but you
know once there were aeba that couldn't
sense what we do and now we are and you
can imagine that in the length of time
that should happen
again um however uh you know we've had
this
conversation uh I've been giving toic
I'm sure everybody else has and over the
past you know n amount of time I'm sure
I've spoken to thousand of people uh
I've published I've been publishing
papers and showing work for decades so
thousands more have have heard what I've
had to say I have no guarantee that even
in this comment let alone this evening
let alone this week month year decade
life I've been
understood the way I would think so so I
have no real valid way of saying that if
you if someone tried to read my mind
they would actually make any sense of
it
so so the question isn't really whether
someone reads my mind and whether or not
I have secrets in there they might be
doing me a favor if they found a secret
that I didn't realize you know and they
pointed out to me the the problem is
really that if I go across across the
city as I will tomorrow go to the VIS
Institute they have little flies that
are drones and there are other people
that have drones that are bigger and the
bigger drones can carry charges and can
can you know shoot at me they can kill
me
because they've misunderstood something
it's quite possible that they'll
misunderstand and quite possible that
they they can terminate me as as I'm
sure people have been terminated in war
zones in the world already by
mistake so the whole conversation that
I'm having is not in the absence of the
technological it's actually because the
technological by itself is really stupid
you know I hate to use such a such a
crude word but really it doesn't
guarantee anything when there are
problems in the world that intelligent
creatures that can put drones not drones
they can put drones on Mars too they can
put Rovers on Mars build the internet
and iPhones and and change genetics and
deal with quantum physics in all sorts
of different ways when such creatures
can't solve problems on the planet it's
because they don't want to solve the
problems on the planet you know the
reason there's the the Narco problem is
because it makes $300 billion dollars in
a couple of years a trillion over a few
years and that's pretty
convenient you know so so all this
veillance in the world isn't going to
solve that because ites you know it's a
problem that doesn't want to be
solved I don't know what what benefit
someone can have by reading someone
else's mind but by misunderstanding I'm
sure they'll think of something and
that's the part that's that's dangerous
if we could figure out now if we could
figure out how to make better sense of
each other and how to have the thoughts
in our mind in a way that we can take
responsibility for them so I don't care
if you go in there what I like is I like
what I like it's my right you know so
what if you know that I'm there I went
down the street I visited that address
yeah that's where I was leave me
alone let's take a question over here I
invite you to be at least as provocative
as mind reading uh well I was actually
going to bring us out of the realm of
Robocop if that's all right but you need
to identify yourself first yes I'm Chris
Peterson from because of the
surveillance um so Sandra you mentioned
the distinction between constitutional
principle and practice we've talked
about the importance of a private
personal sphere to Foster Civic
discourse I'd like to play out something
that Sasha asked about the formation of
Publix which is basically this we've
seen increasing private in the corporate
but not personal sense enclosure of
public spaces on and offline this has
squashed both the physical space for
civic discourse and also the conceptual
space which is something Center that we
talked about in CMS 790 the other day
about no constitutional right for free
speech in Banks uh which kind of alides
the question of of whether or not the
the space whether or not that space is
being squashed in which to speak uh my
question is this what effects will this
continuing enclosure have on Civic
conversations given the importance that
we talked to at the very beginning of
this discussion and what can be done to
help preserve what we valued about them
in this new technological
environment you got a cheat sheet
there um it's a great question let me
just clarify I I did in passing in the
in the course of a class uh say you
don't have a right to to speak in Banks
but I didn't mean actually that there is
no constitutional right but that we have
rules about when you can restrict speech
in privately owned public spaces or
publicly owned spaces that are committed
to specific purposes if the speech or
behaviors in those spaces would disrupt
the purpose to which the spaces are put
just to clarify the Constitutional point
there
um there are many different meanings of
the word public and uh actually the Bank
lobby might be a very good one because
if you are there uh having even a
political organizing convers ation while
you're standing in line you're creating
a public a shared table between you um
that can serve purposes of of political
organization without disrupting the
space even if it's privately owned and
uh under those kinds of restrictions
that are acceptable under us
constitutional law so um the the
privatization act I would take it in
another Direction that's the property
rights one of the things that's
interesting in US law is that even
information that is in the public domain
or is publicly available if it is
processed it becomes uh subject to
property rights and so one of the things
interestingly that the police do is they
take information that is publicly
available process it in their own
databases and using their software and
then it becomes no longer publicly
available and this is uh among the
things that will happen with our with
our with whatever information we're
releasing into the public domain so I
think um the question of uh restrictions
on this U I'm going to I'll take that in
two more directions one is um the issue
of uh ownership of the media and the
quelling of so we have Global uh
conglomeration of the media now eloma
Columbia is tracking this it's not just
Italy it's not just the US uh reduces
the diversity of opinion in the most
public of spheres um there is we know
that well we don't know um some people
say they have evidence that uh in fact
even tweets dealing with the Occupy
Movement have been censored and there's
those kinds of
restrictions um so I think there the
question of where there are restrictions
and when they're meaningfully there is
an important one I'm not sure that the
restrictions are always those that are
getting the most
attention um so I'll I'll stop
there so we've uh We've hit the point of
reloading on questions this is by the
way the clever way around my uh my Sasha
principle uh although I I think we now
have uh uh folks lining up on both sides
I think in interest of fairness I
probably need to give the question to
the person who's yet to ask so let's go
there first well thank you um Joshua
Kaufman from The Graduate School of
Design at
Harvard um I think one way of of reading
these conversations is that uh is that
we have a crisis or opportunity of
agency that with the tools of
surveillance we have new tools of seeing
and new tools of
understanding um and if we're defining
citizenship somehow in the realm of
agency with exposure to new types of
information we have enhanced or
increased agency across the board um
it's a social question or governmental
question um to what extent can can the
our current governance systems absorb
these increased types of agencies can we
rely on them to incre uh absorb these
agencies um should we look elsewhere
outside of traditional um governance um
how should we incorporate increased
agency in in general uh in the realm of
citizenship that's the $6 million
question thank you for asking it um you
got to get up in the morning and you
continue on with your professional
career in one's personal life as a
citizen and as as a human being I'm
um not at all optimistic I don't believe
actually that we are capable of that and
so where does this go it means that um
but but it's the only means that we have
so where it's going in terms of policy
analysis and thinking about the
government is uh analysis of ways in
which law state Society relations are
shifting and that shifts where and this
is going to be too complex to com
something to get into in detail here but
uh it shifts where it is that you want
the regulation and the accountability
and and sort of Designing streams of
accountability and reportage and then
ability to act on that information um so
it it it enormously burdens the
governance system it means in uh we're
beginning to use complex systems
analysis to think about governance
systems incorporating the private
private sector and cultural practices as
well so that's one of the sort of within
the world of of policy thought
development that has been taking place
um and then uh I although I sort of
stake myself publicly on a law and
policy kind of research agenda in fact
there I do include not just the formal
laws and practices and decision-making
entities of geopolitically recognized
governments but also the formal and
informal practices habits um
decision-making entities and processes
of private as well as public sector
entities and the cultural habits and
predispositions that support them uh
both so I think we're at an extremely
difficult moment regarding even the
possibility of effective governments
right now so I want to take a somewhat
different turn um and get technical for
the last few minutes that we're here and
um back in the late 1990s early 2000s
the US Naval Laboratories built a tool
called tour that many of you are
familiar with the onion router uh that
enables uh the hiding of transactional
information who is communicating with
whom and that's very important because
in fact who is communicating with whom
is often far more revelatory than what
the communication is about um in January
2010 after Google announced it had been
broken into by the Chinese government uh
with software taken that pissed them off
quite a lot and also emails hacked um um
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton gave
a speech and it was a very interesting
speech because what it talked about was
the importance of openness and the
importance of the open internet and the
importance of
communication and then this past April
or May uh the White House came out with
its International strategy to secure
cyberspace and it talked about security
talked about cyber exploitation it
talked about all those things but it
talked about the importance of an open
internet and the US government is
putting in a a large amount of money
into securing Communications and hiding
transactional information because they
find it useful of course for human
rights workers for political protesters
and other parts of the world and so on
but you can be sure that those tools
will also be used domestically I'm not
saying this is going to solve the
Privacy problem it's not even close to
solving the Privacy problem but it is an
interesting Ray of Hope in the midst of
all the Gloom that we've been talking
about and it's an interesting Ray of
Hope being promulgated by the US
government Marcus I'm going to give you
the last word you can be hopeful you can
be gloomy you can be in the present you
can be deeply rooted um I I'm I'm always
hopeful and and I think that actually
being optimistic is an ethical
responsibility for anyone who has the
opportunity the mind the talent the will
the time the you know all the all the
resources whatever it takes um so I
would be so anyway but uh I think that
the way way you get to it is by putting
your finger on the actual problem you
know you can't solve a problem you can't
name and I think when you look at the
occupi movements around the world
because it's not just here it's
happening all over the Earth right now
what you're seeing is a clamor that
which is quite quite explicit uh a
clamor for uh a more direct
democracy uh you know a manner in which
what what the deos wants is actually
reflected more immediately uh because
the system that is in place does not
seem to deliver an equitable
distribution of the resources that that
are there without without saying that
all the resources should be equalized
one could say that you know there ought
to be some balance and that balance is
actually articulated as I said in in
Aristotle uh in the politics explicitly
and it's actually taken up and I've
pulled up the the quote it's taken up uh
in The Federalist Papers uh state
statement
17876 26 uh notes of the secret debates
of the federal Convention of
1787 where it's stated that uh uh the uh
the the Constitution that's to be made
ought to be so constituted as to protect
the minority of the opulent against the
majority uh the the the the trick there
is that that
statement um propagates through in a way
that creates all sorts of breaks that
are specifically intended to reduce
agency you know they're intended to put
a put a system of of stops so that uh if
the imbalance becomes too great there's
nothing anybody can do about it and that
is in place and so if any of these
imbalances whether it's economic or
whether it's informational becomes too
great there's nothing anybody can do
about it unless it becomes such a
problem that everybody on Earth all of a
sudden flares up and says enough
you know that seems to be happening if
we were wise we would pay attention and
we would you know pull back and and and
bring everything down but it's not
entirely clear that we're behaving
wisely and so this is where one has to
remember history and realize that you
know there was a French Revolution and
there were people who were saying you
know uh you know eat uh eat cake and you
know their heads rolled you know things
bad things can happen
and it's not really good to be
complacent and it's not really good to
be arrogant and it is good to name the
problem when you see the problem and the
problem is holistic it's not it's not
you know my expertise it's not about my
field it's about us you know there's a
kind of sense of us in a
democracy and over decades that's been
corroded and it's corroded in this
country and it's corroded in all the
countries and and so we we just need to
take
note what I would say in the small polus
that that is the BOS theater this
evening I'm I'm wondering if we could uh
get consensus and uh polite Applause
perhaps for our speakers who've been
provoking us